at this moment we have 22 patients in  the United States currently that have  corona virus unfortunately one person  passed away overnight she was a  wonderful woman a medically high-risk  patient in her late 50s four others are  very ill thankfully 15 are either  recovered fully or they're well on their  way to recovery  and in all cases they've been let go in  their home additional cases in the  United States are likely but healthy  individuals should be able to fully  recover and we think that will be a  statement that we can make with great  surety now that we've gotten familiar  with this problem they should be able to  recover should they contract the virus  you